the dead of taking command of the sea
they're searching for sparrow
pirates life
the dead of taking command of the sea
searching for a girl
pearl and the sparrow man
dead men tell no tales
pirates had infected the sea's for generations
so i thought to eliminate them all
jack sparrow
cursed to me
i will have my revenge
are you sure you "the" jack sparrow
plus wheres your pants
the great part doesnt requires such entosis
find sparrow
carina is the only one who can help us
i'm not looking for trouble
what an horrible way to live
i am woman of science i choose not beleive in ghost
do you not see whats behind us
uhh!!!   monkey
empire is stupid
yes yeah